"Friends" fans around the world were devastated
when Matthew Perry died at the age of 54 — as
were his fellow co-stars. Now, following
a heartfelt group statement from the cast,
Matt LeBlanc has penned his
own tear-jerking goodbye.
LeBlanc, who starred as Chandler
Bing's goofy roommate Joey Tribbiani,
wrote in an emotional Instagram post:
"Matthew. It is with a heavy heart I say
goodbye. The times we had together are
honestly among the favorite times of my
life. It was an honor to share the stage
with you and to call you my friend. I will
always smile when I think of you and I'll
never forget you. Never. Spread your wings and
fly brother you're finally free. Much love."
Fittingly, LeBlanc ended his
tribute with a joke by saying:
"And I guess you're keeping
the 20 bucks you owe me."
In addition to his emotional words, which
reflect on their enduring friendship,
LeBlanc shared several stills
of Joey and Chandler together,
highlighting just how hilarious — and
adorable — the duo were on "Friends."
Honestly, it's hard to imagine a more memorable
sitcom duo. The true definition of "opposites
attract," the lovable goofballs were
frequently at odds with one another,
though they never shied away from mutual
admiration. Their various escapades and side
quests led to some of the most memorable plotlines
in "Friends," such as the time they adopted a
chick and a duck. And who can forget their
hilarious banter in London during Ross' wedding?
"You're different here too!
You're mean in England!"
To this day, the duo's bromance stands out as
a major highlight of the show. Unsurprisingly,
LeBlanc and Perry carried their on-screen
relationship outside of the show's bustling
set. Back in 2015, while speaking with the
Television Critics Association Press Tour,
LeBlanc gushed over his co-star. He said:
"I love that guy. I can not see him
for five years and then get in a
room together and still have a shorthand
with each other. It's amazing, really."
While LeBlanc and Perry were both quite private,
they were occasionally seen together. One of the
duo's most heartfelt crossovers was when
LeBlanc showed up to support Perry for
his debut play "The End of Longing" back in
2016. LeBlanc shared in an Instagram post:
"He and the cast were great. Way to go bro."
Clearly, the two genuinely cared about each other.
As of this video, LeBlanc's Instagram post is
the first major solo statement released from a
"Friends" cast member following Perry's
death. While the core cast of "Friends"
was no doubt close — as evidenced by the
2021 MAX reunion special — Matthew Perry
wished that he could see his former co-stars
more often. He told Access Hollywood in 2022:
"We don't see each other as much. I wish
the group would see each other more."
Perry has always been candid and honest
about his relationship with his co-stars,
frequently praising them at every opportunity.
In his 2022 memoir "Friends, Lovers and
the Big Terrible Thing," Perry opened
up about his brutal history with addiction.
In an excerpt released by The Sunday Times,
Perry discussed how LeBlanc helped
him stay awake on set. He wrote:
"But still, the addiction ravaged me — one time,
in a scene in the coffeehouse when I'm dressed
in a suit, I fell asleep right there on the
couch, and disaster was averted only when Matt
LeBlanc nudged me awake right before my line;
no one noticed, but I knew how close I'd come."
In the same excerpt, Perry revealed how
Jennifer Anniston once confronted him regarding
his addiction, describing the encounter as
"devastating." While they continue to be private
about their personal lives, it's obvious that
the "Friends" cast deeply care for one another.